this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks thanks it's really fun to be here
um
as Bill said I did my undergrad here and
and there were a couple of Faculty
members here when I was an undergrad
specifically Harlan Banks and Dominic
paolillo that had absolutely profound
impacts on my my entire career and by
extension they actually impacted Duke
students for the last 25 years because I
thought of those two Cornell faculty
whenever I encountered an obsessive
plant person and I really wanted to help
them out when they're on the drugs so uh
I have warm feelings for for Cornell so
it's great to be here
um so swagm is one of the larger Genera
of mosses it's also an entire ecosystem
that forms really a subfield of ecology
peel and ecology
um so it's really kind of unique oops
it's really kind of unique in that way
um
Caitlyn's are found throughout the world
uh they're not all sphagnum dominated
peelings especially down in the tropics
but that area in
the north up here I think I'll show this
isn't it no it does not
um that area up in the north these are
mostly almost completely sagam-dominated
penins and they're very important uh
they only cover about 10 of the land
surface of the Earth but they account
for 25 to 30 percent of the entire uh
accumulated pool of terrestrial carbon
so they're pretty remarkable
and they occur where there's a there's a
an unbalance between growth and
decomposition uh so growth can be slow
but if decomposition is either even
slower Then Pete will accumulate and P
to an ecologist has a definition some X
number of centimeters of accumulated
peat uh defines it to a vegetation
ecologist as a p-line and they come in
all different shapes and forms and
they're all almost all absolutely
beautiful habitats to spend uh time in
uh this is a typical Boreal peeling they
may have they may or may not have open
water and where I'm standing out here
would be a floating mat uh on that open
water
really dominated by the sphagnum losses
but they occur as I said all different
shapes and sizes this is appealand in
Southeastern Alaska where it's basically
rain forest kind of the uh ecology uh
and here's a peatland in North Carolina
where I'm coming from and this is a site
that we've gone to many times for
research purposes surrounded by uh bald
cypress
and these peatlands in North Carolina
also happen to be the home of the famous
Venus frog Track by the surprise uh to
see one time when I was there I figure
any plant that is gobbling vertebrates
is one to be a little bit careful of out
of the field
uh but
carbon is stored in peelans they're said
to be a net accumulator of carbon these
days possibly about the change to move a
net source of carbon into the atmosphere
as climate warms but for now and for the
last 10 to 20 000 years they've been uh
accumulating carbon and that's in the
form of P so this is a core through a
appealand and the stagnum is up there at
the top but it accumulates this large
amounts of heat and it's this and it's
basically almost pure sphagnant I mean
there's a there's a number of reasons
why Pete accumulates in the expensive
ecosystems some some of them are
extrinsic these are waterlogged and
natural anoxic kinds of things they're
usually in the Boreal Zone cold climate
but there also are intrinsic features uh
that are characteristic of sphagnum a
variety of chemical uh features that
lead to very low decomposition rates so
you can transplant a sphagnum into a
non-cold
non-anoxic environment and they still
decompose slowly so exceptionally slowly
compared to any vascular plant
so the the the Stars if you will of
these uh peelans is is the genus
sphagnum
um and sphagnant is a moss uh and they
have a very characteristic bowel plan
that makes phagnum uh to my eye at least
relatively easy to recognize compared to
any other Moss they have this capitulum
at the top of the cluster of branches
um and the life cycle is a typical Moss
life cycle so they the free living plant
that you want to encounters out in
nature is the gametophyte typically
haploid but they're score producing so
when they the Spore germinates first
there's an immature tretino model stage
and then that gives rise to a mature
archimedophyte depending on the species
the gametophytes may be unisexual and
different gametophytes have archegonia
female or antheridium male or there are
a minority of species that are bisexual
gametophytes that have both are begonia
and Anthony on the same fertilization
requires water for the sperm to reach
the egg which impacts uh uh dispersal
distances and therefore gene flow
distances but the result is a sporophyte
and the sporophyte is very small uh
basically nothing but a sporangium that
black part up on the top
everything about sphagnum is all about
water storage and control of water
movement
they uh so this is the structure of a
sphagnum plant with that capitulum at
the top with fascicles of branches they
have dimorphic Leaf cells with large
empty dead at maturity hyaline cells and
it enclosed in a network of these green
photosynthetic cells and those hyaline
cells are absolutely chock full of
microorganisms and I work with a lot I'm
not an ecologist but I work with a lot
of people that are primarily interested
in the microorganisms associated with
the sagam and relationships between the
microorganisms and the and the hosts
sign implant and it is a symbiotic
relationship not just an association
so it's Magnum it's the division it's
the phylum or division bryophyta the
Mosses uh it forms a class unto itself
um I'm not going to have time to go into
it today but we've worked on the deeper
level phylogenetics of the stagnopsida
and I will argue that there are three
Genera uh of sphagnopsida two of them
very small and then sphagnum actually
that's wrong for general of sphagopsida
three of them very small and then the
genus phagnum includes uh up
150 to 400 species the the the diversity
of them is not very well understood
which by most standards is actually
quite a large genus maybe not by legume
or grass standards or something like
that but it's a large group and they
have uh these they're they're distinct
from other mosses in virtually every
characteristic of both the gametophyte
generation and the sporophyte generation
including these dimorphic Leaf cells
they typically have no rhizoid you know
losses never have Roots but they're
usually attached to the ground by these
units filamentous rhizoids uh sphagen
has no rhizoids except one species
outside the genostagnum uh that has been
reported with rhizoids and the
sporophyte generation is unique compared
to any other Moss as well
now for
well over 50 to 75 years sphagnum
dominated peatlands have been a model
for Community ecology
oh can you do that
oh I see let's see an X there boy great
mind thank you let's talk about that X
means
um so uh sagam dominated peelins are are
have been a focus for Community ecology
basically because they're relatively
simple communities they're Boreal
communities we're not talking Tropics
here
um and but especially species sort
themselves along Niche space very finely
so they've been they've been a model for
Community assembly uh community
structure and this these figures show a
couple of uh examples of that uh the
species sort very regularly with regard
to hydrological gradients along this one
uh from the center from their margin of
appealing to the center uh this figure
is a accumulated data from you know 50
years of peeling ecology showing how
species sort themselves out relative to
uh cations especially and then in the
bottom tonight a student of mine was
studying a pH variation in terms of the
niche of these species and superimposing
that on a phylogenetic hypothesis and
demonstrated that not only are species
distinct but they're the similarities
and differences are phylogenetically
conserved that it even runs in deep
phylogenetic traits within the genus
fagma
now
hydrologically they've been very very
interesting for peel and ecology they
sort as I said along these hydrological
gradients and you can see a species here
and a species there and the change in
elevation above the water level is
measured in a centimeter or two so
they're very sensitive and you can see
how sharp that is some individual
species are very characteristic of low
so-called Hollows within peeling so this
is sphagen cuspidatum other species at
the other end of the spectrum form
hummus and this has been a focus of
peeling ecology for many years and the
interesting thing about this humming is
you can see that this is strong enough
and big enough for my collaborator to be
climbing across it there's no
topological variation under that Hummock
it's the sphagnum that builds the
Hummock
um in other words there's no ground
change in topology topography so that
hammock Hollow Divergence between
species has gained a lot of attention in
in many years
um and at one end of the spectrum there
are these species that occupy Hollows
and they tend to have high
decomposability
within the context of seconds high
growth rates but they don't form
hummocks because they decompose too
quickly and they don't build up Peak at
the other end of the spectrum they're
species that form hummus they they grow
slowly but they decompose exceptionally
slowly so they build up these hummocks
and we did a meta-analysis a former grad
student of mine and a number of
metabolic and biochemical kinds of
traits and you can see these are
correlated traits suggesting that
there's a whole adaptive syndrome if you
will that underlies this hammock Hollow
topology micro topology Within sphagnum
arguably one of the most interesting
traits to look at is decomposability per
se kind of an interesting trait if you
look at it if you think about it it's a
it's a part of the extended phenotype
it's a phenotype of these plants that
you measure after the plant is dead it's
the rate at which it decomposes and my
student Brian piadkowski
um did quite a large decomposition
experiment as it happens he did it at uh
McLean Bob belongs to Cornell right up
the road here and he he planted out uh
bags of different a whole Suite of
different species of moss let them
decompose for three years and and this
is a standard approach in peel and
ecology and measured variation among
species and also superimpose it on a
phylogenetic hypothesis and found that
decomposability is not only species
specific once again but it's
phylogenetically conserved we know from
people from 50 years of Peel and ecology
we know how these species sort relative
to height above the water table within
peelans that is Hummock height and we
know that there's a correlation and here
the colors correspond to these clades so
there's a clay that tends to be uh High
decomposition low you know these are
Hollow species these are humming species
and then if we take the next step and
superimpose all of this we see that
shifts in Niche uh phylogenetically are
correlated with shifts in decomposition
rates incredibly sensitive
um to changes in Niche I I accuse my
graduate student my then graduate
student of making up the data and
kiddingly because the correlation was so
remarkable
so all of these features of stagnum led
a collaborator of mine Dave Weston at
Oak Ridge National Lab to propose The
Joint genome Institute of stigum Genome
Project and uh we did get that funded
and it created reference genomes for a
couple of species uh sphagnum and
magellanicum and it'll become apparent
in a few minutes why I put that in
quotes uh and sphagnum and gustafolium
and then resequencing a panel of a
so-called diversity panel of other
species and other accessions uh using
that as leverage we got a five-year
biodiversity dimensions of biodiversity
Grant and we resequenced a whole slew of
additional uh accessions representing
the stagna magellanicum which turns out
to be a complex and we also did a lot of
rad seek analyzes because that allowed
us to work with dried material and
increase our sample size Etc
um and we also Dave's lab essentially
worked on sphagnum microbe interactions
and without funding from the doe for
that work and so my two collaborators
most pleasantly are Dave at uh Oak Ridge
and Adam Healey is a computational
biologist who really did the the heavy
listing uh heavy lifting in terms of
dealing with the genome data so I don't
want to spend my time talking about the
Genome Project per se because from my
point of view that's just background
information that facilitates what we
want to do in terms of learning about
Evolution but so I'll just tell you we
there's a high level of symphony between
these two reference quality genomes the
average recombination rate was quite
interesting it turned out to be quite
high
on the same about the same as the the
Moss model fiskimetry and patens about a
third or two-thirds higher than the
model liverwork marcantia and compare
the most vascular plants the
recombination rate in these phagoms are
an order of magnitude higher and that
may that has a number of ramifications
one is that can facilitate adaptive
evolution by a lot of recombination it
can facilitate the purging of
deleterious alleles and um so it's a
useful characteristic
so the only the more or less the only
oil one of two only other things that
I'll tell you about the Genome Project
is that we were through syntony studies
and also studies of genome duplication
we were able to Recon reconstruct the
genome uh of stagnum from five original
chromosomes with a duplication
um and some translocations and to the
current number which is point uniform
across stagnum 19 chromosomes the other
thing that we discovered with this
Genome Project was a previously unknown
very small sex chromosome chromosome 20
and through syntony uh comparisons we
were able to demonstrate that that sex
chromosome which is chromosome 20 uh is
a modified version A reduced version of
chromosome seven so we're able to
pursue that now we did we did a bunch of
work on um the sex chromosome and its
biological significance Etc which again
I'm not going to spend a lot time
talking about but probably the most
interesting result was that we detected
a qtl from doing single Spore isolates
and growing them up that impacted the
growth of sphagnum under pH stress and
as I say down here there's a we we
identified a chromosome we identified a
Locus on chromosome 10 that in males is
detrimental at neutral PHS shown there
but at under pH stress either very low
PH or high pH it actually facilitated it
it reduced the impacts of stress so this
was a really interesting example of
being able to link this qtl to a trait
that impacts where sphagnum grows within
the P lens but also impacts carbon
accumulation so it's in a way it's going
from this genetic interaction to global
scale biogeochemistry it's just a start
but it's a good start from my standpoint
identifying the sex chromosome was most
valuable because it facilitated
Downstream studies of population
genetics population genomics Evolution I
I find the Chrome the sex chromosome per
se extremely interesting but what it
allowed for us
um as more kind of field people and
interested in natural populations was
that it gave us markers for identifying
male and female gametophytes whether or
not they were actually expressing
gametangia the archegonia or enteredia
and since
they're more often than not expressing
not they're they're more often not
expressing gametangia this was a really
valuable tool so we actually developed
two different tools we developed primers
from the U and the V the sex comment
male and female female and male
respectively the U and the V uh sex
chromosomes that could distinguish and
we and we we made sure that they work by
by doing this with plants that we
actually had sexual expressions so we
knew what sex they were and found that
they worked reliably we've been doing
more work with uh rad seek and we
actually developed a method for
distinguishing male and female uh
gametophytes using radc data
um by and I'm not going to go into the
details but by comparing coverage uh to
the coverage of a typical autosome
uh because the the reference genome we
know was one sex or the other and you
know so we we were able to make that
inference and we linked inferences from
this to inferences from here and these
inferences were grounded in known
sexuality so we we know that these work
and
again I'd love to talk to you about sex
ratio biases and clonality and all sorts
of things but I don't have time today
but among other things that allowed us
for example we have one site where we
have a very good microbial data microbes
that are associated with this Magnum and
interestingly enough we found that male
gametophytes at that site had much lower
diversity of microbes associated with
them than females and I'm intrigued by
that because this is a species that has
a female sex bias both in that
population and elsewhere and it raises
some interesting questions about the
microbes may be what's underlying that
sex ratio bias
but what I want to spend the rest of the
time talking about is my favorite
subject these days
um it's this species called sphagnom
agilanicum sphagna magellanicum is shown
a plot of just uh gbif plotted uh
distribution found throughout the world
uh it was described in the in the 1800s
1879 I believe from Tierra del Fuego but
it's kind of a morphologically very
distinctive looking thing it's the only
member of its sub-genus that's read and
so there were similar looking plants in
Europe and North America so they all
became known as sphagnom agilanium and
they've been known as sphagnom
agilanicum from 1879 until about
three years ago and it was great because
even P Lindy colleges could identify
sphagnum magellanic and they didn't have
to be a A stagnum taxonomist or anything
so there's hundreds of papers that deal
with psycho magellanicum in the field
appealing mythology
however
um the bad news started when my
collaborators in Norway got a sense that
there were two different things at a
feeling in central Norway and they uh
used and I think this was rad seat
markers as well and some of you are most
of you are probably familiar with the
program the software structure but if
you're not each one of these circles is
a an individual and it and it identifies
different genetic groups not clones but
genetic groups so suffice it to say for
that and at the site in Norway they
found that there were two isolated
groups there were two completely
distinct genetic groups in what we would
have called sphagnom magellanity they
extended that a bit to a more Global
sampling and found that you know the the
two groups were still distinct but
intermediate individuals were or there
were individuals that were intermediate
in that they were genetically admixed
between those two groups
and they went ahead and described these
two groups as Magnum medium
and which a name already existed in
Europe and sphagnum divinum which they
they or we described as a new species
um and sphagnum magellanic and per se is
limited to Tierra del Fuego for where it
was described because that turned out to
be genetically distinct from both of
them
that's genetic similarity that structure
it's a phonetic kind of approach it's
just genetic differences it doesn't tell
you anything necessarily phylogenetic so
they did with the same data analyze it
in a more of an explicitly phylogenetic
context and found that sure enough
stagnum medium and stagnum dividium
represent two clades very clear clades
and furthermore they they argued or they
documented to some extent that stagnum
de Venom grows typically most commonly
near the margins of P lens and even in
the forests surrounding the penis
whereas sphagnant medium grows out in
the open peelants and so they recognize
that there was some kind of ecological
differences between them well that got
us going because we were you know we
were in the middle of this Genome
Project and our dimensions of
biodiversity project both of them
focused on sphagnom magellanic I mean we
thought uh oh we're in trouble so we
undertook a study and we increased the
sample uh and sampled from here to Lego
but also elsewhere from South America
intensive sampling in North America both
in East and the west and in Europe and
in Asia scattered around a little bit I
should say that our sample size since we
put together this slide is at least
doubled if not tripled but the story
hasn't changed and these are my
collaborators on this work uh martos a
postdoc and Blanca who uh is a staff
person in the herbarium at Duke and my
former student Brian piakowski who was
at the time the oak British national lab
we had a lot of genome resequencing data
and so looking at that first what we
found was that there are indeed sign the
medium the state very there are no no
support values on there because as is
typical with genome data they were all
100 you can get 100 support even if it's
the wrong answer we know that from
genome but I don't bother to put support
values on there so I'm the medium is
there segment divinum uh which are the
two European species but then we
detected two additional things in North
America that hadn't been part of the
European study that seemed to be
something new yet again and then here's
the South American stagna magellanica
which we corroborate was uh
um
distinct from all of these things oh and
well I should I'll just point out I want
to go into this is pulling out pretty
much whole chloroplast genomes and
there's there's some mixing of
chloroplast genomes but uh but a lot of
the mixing is Within These individual
species though not all of them
um but I'll leave that that's a
different story once again uh so we
under we expanded from that genome
resequencing data set with rad seek and
increase the sample size and this
absolutely invisible tree is was the
data at the time but here's a summary of
it that you actually can see and we had
got very well supported
um relationships uh and two different
ways of analyzing it it may only differ
in one little detail so what we see uh
I'm going to focus on the North
Americans species so I've summarized the
relationships among the North American
species uh here medium and medium and
divinum the two that are also found in
Europe but then these two new things
sphagnum magni and stagnant diabolical
that are very closely related sister
species that diverge most recently and
then there were a couple other things
that we did resolve that don't have
names which is why I have kind of
informal names that are not in italics
those haven't been described or have
haven't found an appropriate name for
them yet
this just shows that the rad seek data
well they're just little Snippets from
all over the genome they provide good
coverage of all 19 chromosomes each one
of those vertical lines is a rad seek
Locus so we get good coverage across the
genome and we were able to do analyzes
at the chromosomal level and look at
relationships now you I don't know you
probably can't read these numbers but
the punch line is written up there and
down here this is summarizing numbers of
fixed differences uh between those
species that we had uh rad seek and and
genome resequencing data for it and the
bottom line is as you would as you can
see from their topology Cyclone medium
and divinum differ by thousands in the
case of rad seed potato to millions of
fixed nucleotide differences between
those species whereas these two which
diverge relatively recently differ by
only hundreds in the case of rad seek
data or thousands tens of thousands in
terms of uh genomic sequencing so they
really clearly are uh
those latter two are really clearly much
more closely related and that's shown
here
um here's if you just said this is just
kind of a selected plot to illustrate
this the vitamin medium no question
nothing intermediate and no question
about what represents sort of a
biological species
the structure phylogenetic structure
just turns into a into a a fan when you
get into these species because of uh
interbreeding uh whereas diabolicum and
Maggie uh what this illustrates is
they're clearly distinct from medium but
in this particular case diabolicum is
actually paraphyletic with magni nested
within it and although I didn't have
time to to go into the details
chromosome by chromosome what we found
is that some chromosomes resolve them as
a paraphyletic one nested with a magnet
nested always within diabolic other
chromosomes resolve them as reciprocally
monotheletic but they are very closely
related that's the take-home message
this is what you see if you go out into
the field so these are pictures from one
site
um you know they had that magellanicum
look but they vary in color from almost
completely green some individuals really
completely agree to just deep beautiful
burgundy red and they also vary in
growth form depending on how high of a
Hummock they're forming higher denser
plants uh and lower much looser plants
and so they're incredibly variable in
terms of morphology
now I like to think that especially the
three of us me and my two collaborators
Martin Blanco are really experienced at
going out and looking at sphagnum in the
field and we've been doing this for five
years and I'll be darn we cannot tell
these four species apart in the field
they are morphologically cryptic and
that's really a problem because if we
want to do Downstream studies of you
know ecological differences or
reproductive isolation or phenology
anything that we want to do Downstream
is made that much harder because we
can't go out in the field and know what
we're looking at
so
that is a problem but we we have a
little bit of a work around
um in that we use the genome data to to
to create these barcode markers that do
not need to be sequenced they simply we
we found regions in the genomes that if
we amplify the different species they
will give us different size amplicons
and first we separate medium and divinum
and then within and once you know what
it does at this first LG 9 S1 primer uh
then you go to the subsequent primer and
you can see that's the first step
the smaller and the bigger and then uh
separate the species so this really
really works quite well
not perfect it would be nice to go out
and know what we were looking at but
we've now
um done a lot more sampling and these
barcode markers allow us to resolve what
are the geographic ranges of these
species
and interesting and particularly of
interest is do they occur together could
they interbreed if it's one thing to to
see that they don't interbreed if
they're always allopatric but we need to
know if they occur together with
impedance and could integrate if they're
compatible so this is some sampling that
we've done up and down you can see for
example that it turns out that only
stagnum divinum occurs in Western North
America's as opposed to Eastern sphagnum
magni only occurs in the Southeastern
coastal plain all the way down to
Central Florida whereas the other three
species arboreal or Boreal called
temperate in their distribution so it
really allowed us to understand the
geography of these species and then what
we did is we actually went back and we
sampled a number of populations more
intensively and
and this is the result of that and these
are populations each column is a
population
and the columns show this column is pure
sphagnum to Venum this column is part
sag them divinum and part cyclem
diabolicum and the width of the column
is the sample size so we we looked at
this
what we see is that more often than not
by far these species are occurring
sympatrically and in many cases three
all three Northern species are occurring
in Saint Patrick now feelings are big
places that doesn't necessarily mean
that there's some Patrick at a scale
that matters in terms of mating remember
they rely on water for sperm dispersal
so we actually went back and mapped the
individual samples as we collected them
not having any clue what they were but
then we used the barcodes to identify
them and then we were able to go back uh
because of we geo-referenced each
collection and we found for example that
satnam divinen like the Norwegians
suggests it does often occur in the
surrounding Forest but it also can occur
around the water and we we have any
number of places where three species
occur in close proximity to one another
and this this is just one example map we
see this over and over again at site
after site so they are occurring
sympatrically at a scale that matters in
terms of reproduction
now so we took these sites that are
sympatric these are based on just
sympatric sites and we use structure to
look and ask whether there's genetic ad
mixture and whether if there is genetic
admixture is it at sites where they
occur together so it's suggesting that
there's current gene flow
um and we found the Venom and medium are
absolutely distinct but magni and
diabolic them these two closely related
things really don't differ much at all
except that magni has an additional
genotype group that's present in higher
frequency than it is in diabolicum
and if we do all sorts of paralyzed
comparisons we see what appears to be
complete reproductive isolation now I
want to acknowledge that you can see
something like this and there still
could be some level of introgression so
this is not the final word we're
actually working with this data set
right now to more explicitly test for
introgression in these sites but I want
to focus in the last part of my talk on
sphagnum magni and phagome diabolical
remember this is the phylogenetic
relationships and recall these three
species arboreal cold temperate
magnesium
semi-subtropical to cold warm temperate
and this tends to be an open feelings
and this is in the open Helens and in
the surrounding forests so there's a
little bit of ecological differentiation
and we sampled up and down uh the east
coast and our sample sizes have
increased and this is what they look
like these are these are you already saw
this in a separate picture but this is a
typical Boreal peel and cyanum magni
grows in a place that no self-respecting
sphagnum would ever grow I mean and I'm
used to doing a lot of sphagnum field
work and I'm always bare conscious that
in Alaska it's brown bears it's black
bears I've never had to worry about
gigantic alligators uh when I'm
collecting but those are the habitats
describe the magnet grows in and what we
found again looking at for genetic ad
mixture and lining up our sites along a
latitudinal gradient at the southern end
of the spectrum it's pure magazine at
the Northern end of the spectrum it's
pure diabolical but from new from North
Carolina to New Jersey
almost all the plants are genetically
admined so there's a region which is
basically where the two species
ranges overlap they're genetically odd
mixed so we're interested in those and
we wanted to know you know are we seeing
a signal of incomplete lineage sorting
It's Just Dance Central ancestral
polymorphism or are we seeing a signal
of introgression and so Brian my former
student
uh compared models you know basically uh
coalescence simulations to compare the
best model to explain the patterns that
we saw any tested models where there's
been continuous gene flow since
speciation gene flow at the beginning
and isolation and then secondary contact
or just gene flow uh
briefly subsequent to speciation or
secondary contact only and this by far
was the the most highly supported model
so we do think that there's integration
going on
um between these species we were able
because we have genome sequences for so
many of these we're able to look at a
little bit more detail of what are the
genetic factors that distinguish the two
species and so we did FST scans across
all 19 chromosomes all 19 autosomes and
and identified regions of the genome
that uh were more distinct than you
would expect from background FST values
and it and as it's been found in some
other organisms those high acidos high
regions of differentiation with a lot of
fixed differences occur in these
discrete genomic islands that are
characterized by high FST low genetic
diversity
and so these islands we were kind of
excited about
um
we we knew from that same study that
Divergence between the two species is
heterogeneous across chromosomes so
chromosomes 1 11 and 16.
obviously one 11 and 16. account for uh
40 of all of those windows all of those
outlier Windows uh that we identify
um and they and those outlier Windows
contain over 500 chains for 91 they
weren't just scattered around the genome
91 of all the fixed differences between
these two species occurred in these
discrete genomic Windows
um and 10 of the fixed differences uh
were the within genes so there were 645
uh that result in missense mutations
that are good targets for learning
something functional about what's going
on here
um and the the the pattern of variation
FST dxy and linkage equilibrium Etc uh
again I won't go into the theory behind
all this uh but fits a picture of
predict predicted selection selective
Suites uh accounting for this uh and and
we found through uh McDonald equipment
test uh that there were 10 genes that
showed evidence of adaptive Evolution
among these things and seven of the ten
genes are actually physically in these
genomic Islands so here's a list of the
genes
um
you know I'm not a functional genomicist
so this basically I'm hap I'm happy or
sorry to say is where I stop
um I'm the field guide uh but here are
10 genes that I think
are good candidates for underlying
ecological speciation in this group
um and that may be good candidates to
start for ongoing research on uh what
they're doing and how they impact this
Northern cold adopted species and the
southern worm adopted species uh
differently so
I've been going a mile a minute
I did it purposely because I usually
talk for two hours anyway in a 45 minute
slot
so I I want to just leave you with these
messages you know I want to remind you
that we chose Psych the magellanicum as
one of our Target species for the genome
work because it had this incredibly
widespread Geographic group distribution
in North America alone it extends from
you know sub-arc to Canada all the way
to uh alligator ridden there swamps in
Florida
um and we thought what and part of our
bio dimensions of biodiversity research
was to study
differential adaptation along that
latitudinal song
um so we went into it and we realized
early on that segment magellanicum isn't
one species it's seven species at least
seven species I will note that we don't
really have samples from Africa or
Western South South Asia so at least
seven species
um I think we seem to have caught
speciation in the ACT especially in the
diabolic
they're they're incompletely isolated
reproductively they're much less
genetically Divergent than the other
pairs of species
Etc so it's it turns out that well and I
will say well it turns out that the
group is not only a great group for
pursuing climate adaptation because it
does include
Northern sub-arctic species and
subtropical species it's just not within
one species but what we've learned is
this is also a tremendous system for
studying speciation I would argue one of
the best in bryophytes
um
so we're very excited to move forward
and so far we've really focused on on
Divergence that is you know what are the
fixed differences where are they in the
genome you know what genes are they part
of Etc but we're also very much
interested in this issue of integration
which we've started to get at and there
would be lots of and I will say that if
NSF had been more Cooperative last year
we would be doing that right now but
maybe next year
um to really pursue what's going on with
integration and doing a common Garden
qtl kinds of based uh studies with this
so I'll leave you with um obviously I'm
a small Cog in the in the program here
uh we have we've had good financial
support from the National Science
Foundation and from the Department of
energy both jgi which is Department of
energy but also separate Department of
energy grants for the microbial work but
I didn't really have a chance to talk
about
um at Duke uh
one of my graduate students Karen who
just finished sadly my last graduate
student I think before retirement had
several postdocs as well as Blanca who
works in the herbarium we all have
worked together in this Brian and Dave
at Oak Ridge National Laboratory Hudson
Institute of biotechnology did the
genome sequencing for jgi and also our
Dimensions
um support the genome sequencing Jeremy
oversees that Adam is the computational
biologist without whom I would have just
had my eyes rolling with the data and
then also a couple of field field
colleagues who have played a big part
Sean Robinson who I was in the field
with yesterday collecting these things
at a site Murphy Syracuse and Scott
shooty who took me around to Caitlin's
all over Pennsylvania as part of that
sympatri study to see what grows where
and with that I will I will finish
[Music]
so I might have a little bit of time for
the questions you'll look for my
prescribing differences well we've I
have we published a paper a couple years
ago with a very detailed microscopic
studies and the conclusion was simple we
can't tell them apart really thorough
every every character I could look at it
did there they really are
cryptic morphologically cryptic I'm not
I haven't given up we're still working
on this to learn how to tell them apart
but
they're pretty darn similar to follow
that question
right
all you have are some some jealous
well it's not the first time I've been
faced with that and I've you know to
fulfill the the letter of the law in
some years past I said you know for the
species diagnosis the mutation of an a
to a T at site 327. in this case you
know I had to do the same thing it just
these two species just came out a couple
of months ago or yeah six months ago and
you know we had say you know
like sphagna magni is often green much
less commonly read and we just said
sagnom magnet off in green much less
commonly red completely useless for
identifying the species we were simply
fulfilling the nomenclature legal
obligation it's a problem and there are
people that hate our guts for describing
these things and I had many discussions
with people
both at Duke and outside and we had the
sending views even within Duke within
our group you know these shouldn't be
described as separate species but my
argument is they are very important
units of biodiversity climate wise
niche-wise evolutionarily they have to
be named if they can't be distinguished
morphologically well I apologize but you
know but there's more to taxonomy than
just identifying specimens there's
cataloging biodiversity and important
biological diversity that's my skill
wait a minute
oh no evidence not if I wish you know
Spangled is a great model for many for
genomic kinds of things but one of the
biggest problems is that no one
including us has learned how to grow
sphagnum from a sport to mature to
sexual maturity and do a cross
so we are really limited so far
in in you know what we can do
genetically
well we've looked at other complexes of
species and the answer is sometimes yes
sometimes know there's plenty of species
that are just clearly distinct and when
you look at them you know relative to
you know
widespread sampling and also relatively
related things it doesn't turn out that
they're part of conferences but there's
another complex that's not that far from
this
in the same sub genus that I'm very
excited to study it's really I have no
molecular work at all and it also
uh has one species that's sub-arctic and
another one that's
subtropical it's got all the all the
attributes that I've been looking for
for an interesting system so not all of
them
which one the segment group acne Bethany
Austin bricada
this
you know
I don't think there's been I mean there
hasn't been as much experimental there's
been a lot of descriptive
studies you know where they grow
relative to pH for example or whatever
but not nearly enough experimental
studies really assessing
how they're impacted
by if that's your question so there's
virtually nothing known
a lot of a lot of humor lifetimes of
research on this group
information
[Music]
in the ecological you mean in the
nomenclature descriptions of the species
well we didn't know them at the time
we knew we knew the molecular
phylogenetics
um and we did say something I guess
about Niche differences but you know the
niche differences
um are subtle there's a lot of overlap
they're not clear Niche differences as
you can see from that one map taking all
all of them grow together
oh I don't know whether I want to oh
then now my son
and he's a foodie you guys jeez
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu